This is
the motherboard for the Super Nintendo,
a 16 bit video game console that came
out in 1991 in America,
and these are the sound chips that
worked in tandem to create all the audio
sound effects and music that you heard
in Super Nintendo Games.
The first chip,
the SMP or the SPC 700 was a processing
court,
were a video game.
Musician could essentially write the
program that would tell the other chip,
the DSP,
what sounds to me,
whereas the original nes sound chip had
just five channels and could really only
do creative variations on the same basic
sound.
The Super Nintendo had eight dedicated
channels and used a sampling system
which meant that artists could load in
noises or sound effects from instruments
of their choosing with room for eight
simultaneous instruments and the ability
to sample different sounds.
The Super Nintendo was a big improvement
over its predecessor,
but there was still one huge limitation
between the two chips.
The system could only accommodate for 64
kilobytes of audio ram.
To give you a sense of how small that
is,
an average three minute MP3 song that
you might buy on itunes is around six
megabytes,
which is 100 times the size of the
super.
Nintendo is full capacity and that's
just for one song.
The 64 kilobytes had to hold all the
music and the sound effects for an
entire game,
which is why you often got music that
sounded well,
not that great.
When you think of sampling in popular
music,
you might think of someone taking a few
seconds of an old drum beat and using it
in new song.
Call it a sample that's even a few
seconds long,
carries a whole lot of information in
order to stay within the allotted 64 k
super nintendo music samples had to be
kind of walking all the way down to a
single cycle of a wave form.
In order to make good music with these
limitations,
you had to be creative.
What you're hearing now is aquatic
ambience from 1994.
His Donkey Kong country,
a classic by one of video games.
Best Composers,
David wise wise,
was able to ring beautiful music from
the limitations of the nintendo sound
chips.
For example,
the evolving swimming background patents
that you're hearing in the song sweeps
like this,
just work possible on the Super Nintendo
and sampling something.
This long and complex would have quickly
exceeded the capacity of the system.
So why has had to think outside of the
box.
One of the most important features of
the wave station is the ability to
string together a number of waves.
Waves can be defined as single and
motorcycle loops.
With more than 400 internal waves
available,
you can select up to 255 different to
play in any order,
including trace of pitch duration and
cross fade time wise,
took inspiration from the cord wave
station,
a synthesizer that came out in the early
nineties and use something called wave
sequencing to take a number of tiny
samples and play them in quick
succession so that they made unique
evolving sounds.
Of course the Super Nintendo couldn't
arrange and rearrange samples on its
own.
So in order to achieve this effect wise,
painstakingly recorded individual wave
forms at different frequencies and place
them all in the coding program,
one by one.
This program,
by the way,
is called a music tracker where music is
essentially boiled down to numbers.
Each tiny sound is placed on a vertical
timeline and the columns represent your
note octave,
sample choice volume in some simple
effects like panning,
feed and echo.
It took wise five full weeks to input
every sample for aquatic ambience.
It's a tedious process,
but the results speak for themselves.
The Super Nintendo was restrictive
system for composers.
There's no doubt,
but as with any limitation breeds
creativity because the sound system
consists of two chips,
64 kilobytes of Ram and a lot of
hexadecimal code doesn't mean it can't
make beautiful music.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
verve.
Verve is a service that pulls together a
lot of great content channels like
rooster teeth,
Mondo,
crunchy roll,
and funimation all into one place so you
can watch some of the best anime there,
but they've also added new channels like
movie which hosts a rotating roster of
30 indie movies,
which is something that I love.
Another show that I would personally
like to recommend is gary and his demons
about a dude who is destined to fight
demons but doesn't really want to do it.
It's.
It's a funny show.
Kind of like rick and morty.
I feel like that with verve premium you
can get ad free access to Gary and his
demons and everything else,
all the channels,
and for a limited time you can use the
first link in the description to get a
30 day free trial of verve.
Definitely try that out.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.